1850 les engagés indiens sont débarqués
pour une quarantaine au lazaret de la
grande chaloupe ne savent pas que leurs
présents sur cette île va contribué au
peuplement de la réunion 2014
nous sommes 25 élèves du collège antoine
soubou de saint paul à découvrir l'inde
sur les traces de nos ancêtres
dans le cadre du 350e anniversaire du
peuplement de l'ariane l'arrivée à delhi
donne lieu aux premières réflexions ou
la journée de repos prévue se transforme
en répétition il y en a bien besoin
on reste édition se fera à l'alliance
française dans deux jours ils vont être
à la hauteur et tout le monde participe
les élèves de classe de français nous
reçoivent à dps milda une école privée
de la banlieue de des lions au début les
échanges sont timides
mais les correspondants de mettre
rapidement à l'aise
c'est la décoration des carnets de
voyage qui va créer des liens entre les
différents élèves
les correspondants ont préparé le repas
chez eux de nouvelles saveurs
beaucoup de piment tout le monde déguste
une brise on s'est rendu compte de la
différence des ans lors des exposés
serait ce dû à un manque de travail de
notre part vivement la travail sont très
présents comparez albano on a ressenti
un vrai travail pas comme nous ils ont
fait beaucoup d'efforts se sont beaucoup
investis
alors que nous faisons du copier coller
ce matin nous passons devant leur est
forte et notre guide favori ramesh nous
a organisé la découverte en rickshaw du
hall delhi capitale de la musulmane
pendant trois siècles et elle me fait
penser à quelqu'un
oui c'est un langage et on a vu la photo
au lazaret à la réunion
m
voilà partie des musées est amoindri qui
a même pu tuer mais on voit des gens qui
passe dedans
eh bien nous accompagnons maintenant un
groupe de fidèles
ils viennent de tout l'homme nous
précise ramesh ils vont se recueillir
sur la stèle de marbre qui marque le
lieu au mahatma gandhi a été incinéré en
1948 aujourd'hui nous passons la journée
avec nos correspondants et langues se
délient on commence la journée par une
visite du pit a mis des liens qui
construit et détruit huit fois le
primaire partie de l'île aux anciens cet
homme-là de première main ce qui relève
et coûte au final c'est le symbole de
délit pour lequel à paris emprunté et
peut-être volcan les symboles
vous voyez la rupture montbard
il faut ça les fait rire tout à l'heure
la différence avec l'architecturé du sud
qui n'est pas du tout le même travail
nous avons un nouvel ami il s'agit du dr
tout aussi on aime bien plaisanter pour
nous faire comprendre les choses flo de
la fia
ce n'est pas une posture il a les
défauts en pollution en tout cas ça
ressemble bien aux temples de chez nous
tout le monde est sur son 31
notre travail autour de l'inde est
présenté ce matin à l'alliance française
aujourd'hui l'huile a bien coupé car si
c'était un bien vivre ensemble
ma remarque l'ensemble à faire péter une
exposition photo le brave généalogique
sur un logiciel
remercions ce conseil général 2 avoir
offert ce beau voyage au nom de
l'ambassade de france en inde je voulais
vous remercier d'avoir pu commencer un
second projet d'avoir fait en sorte que
ces élèves puissent vivre une expérience
qui sera mémorable pour eux et d'avoir
fait ce continuer à provoquer ce lien
particulier qu'il ya entre la france et
l'inde
merci à vous mission accomplie certains
sont excités à l'idée de se retourner
seul avec leurs correspondants et
rencontrer leurs familles ces quelques
jours d'échangés et de partage c'est un
nid en beauté sur la scène de l'école
dps noida
j'aime chloé exprime tout le monde à dos
à dos et son demi frère comme une
faiblesse du yunnan province d'attopeu
cinétique ils ont plus là nous sommes
respect que nous enlever nos parents ils
font tout pour apprendre pour réussir
pour une gêne plus mature après une
petite mise au point tout le monde s'est
dit au revoir le coeur ça
aujourd'hui départ tu pourras gras
capitale de l'uttar pradesh
nous allons à la rencontre d'élèves
d'une école publique qui accueille des
malvoyants et des malentendants
la bienvenue aussi plus
traditionnellement avec les petits lacs
et les colliers de fleurs
nous installons face à face les regards
sont intenses
l'émotion est à son comble lorsque les
cadeaux s'est échangé avec beaucoup de
délicatesse
la prise de conscience est générale
cette rencontre nous marquera à jamais
c'était triste ça m'a fait pleurer
ben ça va toucher au coeur parce que la
toux et ils ont bien fait
comme ça nous avons su comment
passé ce temps nous a un peu secoué on
va dire parce que eux ils sont heureux
d'être là et nous souvent alico 1 600
gang semaines de cours pourquoi sipa le
week-end ils sont heureux d'être à
l'école moi je pense que ça va changer
ma manière de travailler un peu de
marche à pied remet tout le monde de ses
émotions et singe malicieux pour leurs
effets agra abrite aussi l'une des
merveilles du monde un rêve de marbre
ces empereurs chadjaa nk l'a érigé pour
inhumer la dépouille de son épouse bien
aimée montage mal
l'élu du palais
c'est plus qu'un rêve
si le titanic ravi
départ pour jack bauer à la vue de tous
ces cheminées destiné à la cuisson de
briques de terre
nous comprenons mieux la pâleur du ciel
ce restaurant ne marquera aussi ou plus
tout notre système digestif
sur la route nous n'arrêtons devant un
atelier de senstock c'est de la pierre
de sable qui est travaillé de manière
ancestrale
nous découvrons que les bas-reliefs
ressemble fortement à certaines
décorations de maisons créoles près un
artisan au fusil avec dextérité les
poteries seront simplement séché au
soleil sur le toit
tout comme les bouses compact est
utilisé comme combustible
hier
un texte pour le facebook du collège
pour coordonner les informations aux
parents sachent que
abyei pour capitale du rajasthan
l'originalité architecturale et de
nouveaux rendez-vous une des perles jay
pour et le ford amber que nous allons
rejoindre à dos d'éléphant ce sera un de
nos meilleurs souvenirs
notre guide bajrang fait de son mieux
pour tout expliquer 966
m
courant
nous découvrons maintenant une
manufacture de tapis fabriquer de la
même manière depuis des siècles certains
d'entre nous ces seuils tissage se
rendre en succès
quelle mentalité
sur la route de la soie la ville est
toujours riche et aliments c'est ici que
nous choisirons des souvenirs pour nos
familles sur le départ pour délit nous
quittons le rajasthan et ses plus
vieilles montagnes du monde
certains profitent de ces quelques
heures en car pour illustrer leur carnet
de voyage l'envol pour la réunion se
fait dans la foule le voyage aura été
enrichissante pour tout le monde
pour nous le voyage s'est bien passé par
rapport les enfants et donner de
nouvelles tous les soirs sur internet
ça nous a rassurés
pour qu'il grandisse un symbole ça va
nous permettre d'essayer pour les
séances de ski ça sort de là bas je
crois que c'était un voyage très
enrichissante ça change beaucoup de
choses chez moi de ce que j'ai vu de ce
que je ressens tu y rendit à ce pouvoir
quelque chose
la vidéo
vasari la page
enrichi